from HEA explosions to Molotov infernos
grenade kills might be rare but they're
always awesome so not including impact
kills here are our picks for the top 10
grenade kills in csgo history let's kick
off our list with the long-distance boom
check out Roca throwing arm as he
detonates shroud go along has an aka to
work with but doesn't have a lot of
health anymore they just took most of
that away he's down to 7 has to fall
back molotovs himself out to buy himself
some space but what he forgets about is
the flying grenades
Fifi's carpet bombing of drop room
against titan takes number 9 on the list
oh and the fact that scream accidentally
needed his own team is just the icing on
top of the high explosive cake maybe
maybe you made it there on an old boat
along with some recipe Wow not okay that
I've never seen a couple spit before
what a start from vs. pro triple or
double Nate okay well thank you thank
you for playing
Pasha's explosion of gambit drops in at
number eight perfect timing perfect
camerawork and boom
beautiful get a bit of a money bonus so
they keep buying even more stuff in the
next round Renee's gonna paint at the
feet oh my god Pasha a nuclear bomb
exploding dosha Hobbit it takes some
kind of tactical clairvoyance to Nate
stack drop on the first round of a game
but Dignitas did just that in our pick
for number 7 let's go for we're heading
towards B but it looks like it's maybe
the drop-down split towards a as the
form is towards middle right now pick
grenades coming in as grenades paying
dividends as they have tense key fix of
a double coat taking unhappy pronax is
iconic moly 3k against cloud 9 comes in
at number 6 on the list cloud 9 might
have missed played the situation badly
but you can't deny this play has lived
on and it's in Tunisia it's all Caesar
doubt that that's gonna slow things down
tries to prime time skadoodle will get
him and the off have they got time
they're just gonna set up bad sit
while the play itself is pretty standard
Happy's diffuse stopping need earns
number five because of the stakes in
which it happened even in a key round in
the finals of the major happy didn't
miss Kobe pickle time is that happy
holding the high ground hoping to be
able to want to see a thing of beauty
check out this take of a site cash buy
team Acer who's perfect molotovs
placements leave alien tech no choice
but to burn them all times they have
five molotovs they had better just like
napalm this site like fire bomb like
that is some excellent work from team
acer angel's destruction of eFRAG net
slew stack is a slam dunk for number
three it's seldom we see three kills
with one name and the 80 damage on spy
leader is just a sweet bonus TAS is
roasting of TSM takes number two on the
list not only because it's a great play
but for the hilarious commentary by
James Bartles absolute something may be
going for segue hey once again they're
gonna go for it boss as push but they're
gonna block each other in the Molotov
and it's gonna be three people then
accessory but it's a Sunday race we're
talking Yorkshire pudding beef chicken
everything order to play at the same
time I'm gonna be obese by the time this
round is finished and now for the number
one spot on the list
could it really be anything other than
go just 200 IQ high explosive Nate from
the pgl major bring Moy this is huge
George is gonna made into the corner
just as the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and those were our picks for the top 10
grenade kills in csgo history did we
miss any of your favorites let us know
in the comment section below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button